así
en el vídeo y ejercicio pasado vimos
como una tabla es una muy buena forma
para contar distintos tipos de robots
donde cada robot está hecho de una
cabeza y un cuerpo llamémosle a cada uno
de esos robots distintos una combinación
tú estás rodeado de combinaciones todo
el tiempo por ejemplo cuando te
despiertas en la mañana y escoges una
blusa y un pantalón esa es una
combinación observa que como cada celda
de la tabla corresponde a una
combinación distinta únicamente
necesitamos contar el número de celdas
pero no tenemos que contarlas una por
una
y eso es porque la cantidad de celdas en
una tabla es la multiplicación de la
cantidad de filas por la cantidad de
columnas así es que con dos cabezas y
tres cuerpos
tenemos dos por tres o sea seis
combinaciones distintas ahora sí tenemos
tres cabezas y cuatro cuerpos entonces
tenemos tres por cuatro o sea doce
combinaciones distintas en el próximo
ejercicio vas a tener la oportunidad de
practicar con otras combinaciones